نعم بالفعل فاطمه كما ذكرتي ما زال هناك
امل
بانتشال احياء من تحت الانقاذ وما زالت
عمليات الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه كما ذكرت نحن في كهرمان مرعش
يعني مركز الزلزال في جنوب البلاد وهي
متضرره جدا وبلده منكوبه
تعاني جدا نتيجه هذا الزلزال وكما تشاهدين
خلفي من الصوره سنضع الكاميرا تريكم
المشاهد في هذا الحي كم حجم الدمار الهائل
الذي لحق بهذا الحي نتيجه الزلزال وما زال
عمال الانقاذ كما تشاهدين بالصوره يحاولون
الوصول الى
عالقين تحت الانقاض سمعنا من يعني
شهود عيان هنا ان هناك
ناجينا في هذه المناطق حيث يعملون الان
تحت هذه الانقاذ ويعني ما زالت الامال
موجوده بوجود ناجين ما زال هناك يعني
اشخاص يخرجون على قيد الحياه بعد اكثر من
عشرين ساعه تم انقاذهم وتتواصل هذه
العمليات حتى هذه اللحظه رغم تضاءل فرص
النجاح بعد يعني مرور سته ايام فاطمه من
الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه البلاد طبعا هذه
بلده منكوبه هذه الاحياء التي تشاهدينها
بالصوره الان لا يوجد فيها اي احد من
السكان تم اخلاء واجلاء سكان هذه المدينه
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضربها وبسبب يعني خطوره
العوده الى هذه المنازل وايضا لا توجد
مظاهر للحياه اصلا هنا بسبب هذه بسبب هذا
الدمار الكامل طبعا الكهرباء مقطوعه عن
هذه المنطقه والمياه مقطوعه عن هذه
المنطقه وما زال العمل مستمر حتى هذه
اللحظه ولك ان تتخيل حجم الاطنان فاطمه في
منطقه كهرمان مرعش ويعني حجم الجهد
المبذول من فرق الانقاذ